[Music]
in 2019 oil giant bp began a huge
project that would pay dozens of
communities across mexico to protect
their trees and reforest using carbon
offsets wall street's favorite climate
solution each offset would represent a
ton of carbon absorbed thanks to the
promise of payment in these low-income
communities however when bp made its
first payment last year it gave
villagers just a fraction of market
rates
[Music]
the mountain community of coyotetila in
eastern mexico used to be cradled by
rich pine forests but over the years
villagers had to chip away at the trees
for logging and farm work in a place
where on the rare occasions that can
find work the average pay is just 6.50
per day
[Music]
dozens of villagers across mexico
thought they found a way to protect
their forests and earn crucial income
when they were approached by officials
from bp's project
integrated
became one of the first communities to
be paid by the program but at just over
forty dollars per person it was a
fraction of what they've been hoping for
and a climate bargain for bp which could
sell the offsets for three or four times
that amount on the market
is
[Music]
ep says the program was helping develop
rural areas but the low pay was a blow
for a community where most young men
have to leave their home for work
[Music]
the low pay doesn't just harm the
villages it also damages the chances of
the program's environmental success
which depend on the forest being
preserved for decades
for example
a few weeks after the people of kurta
complained about the low prices they
were told that bp would be increasing
their pay
the program's administrators confirmed
to bloomberg that the villagers would be
getting a raise but wouldn't provide
details
the increase didn't stop mexico's
president weighing in on the story
[Music]
yes
[Music]
for now the community is hoping for a
better second payment while struggling
with soaring inflation
at present nearly all of this young men
spend the year travelling for labour
they hardly see their kids grow up and
poor pay robs them with the chance to
spend more time at home with their
families